hey I'm John Cena bark reporting
unofficially for apparently wired you
can you can't quite make out the logo
but it's on here this is the unveiled
event that CES does is loaded with
writers and journalists is terrible I'll
tell you something there's at least from
my count there's three or four writers
or journalists for every booth at this
show that's what kind of show we're
talking about here in this event you
can't really get up to anything to see
what's going on but I did go see the 3d
there's a 3d display over here that uses
micro polarization it's kind of
interesting Samsung's also got a cool
camera and then there's a bunch of
gizmos all over the place headphones
breakthroughs maybe you put them on your
over your ears and then you can listen
to your ipod fantastic back to you and
ELISA
you